welcome to building a virtual
post-production suite with google cloud
my name's adrian graham and i'm a cloud
solutions architect for media and
entertainment
and i'm also here with my colleague buzz
hayes who's global lead for industry
solutions for media and entertainment
and we're going to show you a deployment
today that involves content creation on
the cloud and we're going to talk about
how to migrate your entire workload to
the cloud
to create an entire facility a virtual
facility that can span the globe
i'm also going to bring in buzz hayes
right now to talk about
some of the business use cases and some
of the complexities
around building this facility buzz
thank you so as you can imagine you know
studio is under a lot of pressure these
days to create content
um under deadlines certainly but also
with uh significant cost constraints on
it and the quality bar
keeps going up and up and up the
audience demand for quality content
is going through the roof and so we need
to find ways to
support anyone who's creating content
with the resources they need to be able
to deliver
this content because we're an
increasingly globalized
workforce we're looking to try and tie
together resources from all over the
world which presents its own challenges
as well
and by having an inflexible
infrastructure for example that would
require people to be on-prem
for any given task is really quite
restrictive
so what we're looking at in the grand
scheme of things
is the ability to transform
the infrastructure required by using
what we refer to as the virtual
post-production suite in this case
so by taking advantage of
uh what we know about cloud and looking
at existing architectures
of the way people currently do things we
can come up with optimal solutions
as you can imagine the schedules are
quite tight for delivering content these
days
and resources can be very constrained
for no particular reason other than you
have to get a project out the door
you may not have enough compute
resources so you have to find some
alternative for that
because profit margins are so thin
typically on productions there's not
really much time or money available for
research and development to find new
ways to do things
on-prem so taking advantage of cloud is
is definitely
something to think about with talent
shortages the way they are
talent being dispersed all over the
planet sometimes finding a way to get
these people to collaborate when they're
in disparate locations around the world
becomes its own set of challenges
and because of the the high cost of
keeping
hardware and people on-prem there are a
lot of considerations that have to be
taken into account
when you're trying to budget
appropriately for a film again or a tv
show
especially because again these margins
are so slow and then
one of the things that's missing from
any of these uh
particular workflows is the ability to
capture the actual workflow itself so
that's what we talk about when we talk
about
this idea of a virtual studio
environment where the production company
of record owns all the resources
required to make a production
from inception all the way through the
archive and as part of that we are
archiving the workflow which is
something that's been missing
up to now so as we look forward um
there are different applications for
using
cloud resources and they apply to
virtually every department on a project
so as you can imagine when a project
starts it's typically in the business
office right where they're starting with
the
the production administration side of
things it eventually will step into
a mode where you're working with artists
in a previous mode so they start to need
different compute
resources for that uh editorial is
probably the longest phase of any given
production so it will start early and
last and often is the repository of all
of the visual
and audio information that comes through
a production so it becomes sort of a
central hub that's a very important
thing to acknowledge
uh visual effects because there are so
many uh
visual effects artists in the world
contributing to movies these days there
are assets that are all over the place
that need to be centralized in order to
make that a more efficient process
and then as we start to finish these
things through color correction and
finishing
we need resources to be able to pull
down these very high resolution files
to be able to work on in real time
essentially uh sound post production is
another area where we can take advantage
of cloud
and certainly the mastering and the
versioning
there are so many different versions of
any given title these days it's
important to leverage
as many parallel resources as possible
again a great use of cloud
so when we talk about provisioning of a
studio or in this case a virtual post
production suite in the cloud it starts
with workstations
those workstations can have very
different tasks some can be just
spreadsheets for
handling budgets and schedules others
start to use visual tools
today we're going to be talking about
some creative visual tools
and then once you start bringing the
editorial component you have editing
software you have all these visual and
audio assets that have to be maintained
so that requires a lot of storage
renders
come from all different places there are
trans codes that are just a way to get
stuff into the right form to work with
but then there's also all the visual
effects rendering so we need an
infrastructure that's scalable for that
we also need to be able to control where
all these assets
are where they live and who they belong
to who has permission for these things
so centralizing asset management means
that essentially you have a single
source of truth
in cloud where no one who isn't supposed
to have access has access and everyone
who
is supposed to have access has the
proper access but the management of
those assets is centralized
and finally we deal with the archive as
something from the
very beginning of a project where we
want to make sure that we know when
assets are created
where do they belong in the grand scheme
of things ending up with the archives so
that any part of the process including
the workflow
can be recreated now as we look at the
different types of
uh resources available to folks to use
we really have to think about the people
the teams that are working with this
stuff so it's important to build
virtual workstations that cert that
serve the need
of the artist that's using this
particular workstation
we need to be able to then deliver these
workstations to wherever the people
happen to be in the world
and as part of that we need to
orchestrate how all these things talk to
each other the networking involved the
security involved the storage all of
that
especially when these uh resources are
sprinkled across the planet
so we need reliable storage we need
the ability to scale up render resources
as we need them and we shouldn't have to
pay for them if we're not using them
and we need the ability to archive this
entire infrastructure
at the end of a production so the way we
look at this is kind of in two different
skus one
is more the enterprise level where we're
talking about
companies that may have a number of
editing suites
each suite is assigned a given
production and those assets are then
deployed to that particular suite but
they come from a common set
you can think of broadcasters as a good
example of this but there
are other more siloed productions where
a feature film or an independent
production
doesn't need access to any resources
from any other projects they only
require their own so this idea of a
virtual post-production suite in a
virtual studio
applies to either of these two
situations
now as we look at how we connect all of
these
folks from around the world and all
these resources it's important to note
that google is a private network
so if you have all of these people and
resources that need
access to their materials they're all on
the same network no matter where they
happen to be
in on the planet and that's a really
important consideration it's as if
they're all
in a very large building together and
they have access to the resources
they need
now security is something that always uh
has to be mentioned
when it comes to any form of cloud
whether it's compute or storage
but when it comes to the media industry
they're very sensitive obviously to
the security aspects of the media so we
take that very seriously we're part of
all the major industry organizations
we're part of the trusted partner
network we work with the isc
and the motion picture association of
america we go through regular audits
we really understand that security is
paramount in in terms of
how these productions get done and the
level of secrecy involved in keeping
these things under wraps until such time
as they
they make it out to the world so we take
this idea of security extremely
seriously
and we have a number of rendering
workloads solutions that you can find
uh on the google website that would help
point you in the right direction but
again we we take security very very
seriously especially when we start to
distribute uh the the resources around
the world
so with that i would like to turn this
over to adrian who's going to talk a
little bit about a specific
implementation of the virtual
post-production suite
and how all the pieces fit together
adrian
thanks buzz um i'm going to take us
through an example architecture of what
a virtual post-production suite
some of the components that it's built
out of um and then we're going to show
show one in action but i want to start
by talking about how to gain access
to our to our resources and you could do
that from any type of workstation or
laptop
or some sort of a hardware client or a
thin client
and this could be a windows mac linux
chrome os device
it doesn't matter because you're just
viewing pixels and the pixels are
streaming
uh in a particular format we'll talk
about that in a second but to get into
our network to get into google cloud
platform
you want to be able to securely connect
to the resources and to do that we're
using what's called a connection broker
and the connection broker is very
important because it serves two main
purposes number one
it authenticates the user it provides
connectivity to an
uh to an identity service such as iep
or with g suite or some sort of active
directory service
and it can also drive things like
multi-factor authentication to send a
push notification for example
to a mobile device uh to authenticate a
user
and the other main function that that it
performs the connection broker performs
is matching users to resources so when
resources are assigned to a user
the connection broker authenticates and
will connect the user
to their virtual workstation now what
this diagram does not show
are different regions around the world
and you could have artists working
in uh in los angeles like me or in
uh in europe or in tokyo or anywhere in
the world that there's a google data
center
and run your virtual workstations and
connect those connect artists in those
locations to the virtual workstations
you heard buzz earlier speak about
regionality of where artists
you want to go where the artists are and
take advantage of things like
production tax credits for example you
want to be able to spin up a studio
where those production tax credits or
the artist pools are available
and you can do that by deploying
resources there and putting a connection
broker there
now once you're on your virtual
workstation you have access to all the
typical things that you would
enjoy with a a machine that's under your
desk or
at work or at home and you've got things
like shared file systems
that can be mounted as either semba or
nfs
and uh because they're shared they are
available for read write to all users in
a project
um users in different regions there's
strategies for synchronizing data
between shared file systems
uh so there's some patterns around that
you also have connectivity to things
like asset management databases
um so that you could centrally store and
manage your assets and do things like
metadata tagging
on them and bring the uh the the
software that you typically use on prem
you could bring that into the cloud
to provide asset management so you again
you're providing your
artists with a familiar environment that
they should be indistinguishable from
your on-prem
and finally there's strategies around
archiving and storage
to be able to offline for example shots
that final shots
or to be able to move data around
around a network there are some storage
strategies in which you use object data
or object storage as uh not as archive
but as a back end for
uh for a different shared file system uh
we could talk about some of that uh
we talked about a little bit of that in
the demo
but before we jump into the demo i want
to talk about the technology that we're
using to stream
the the remote desktop to the endpoint
to our our
client and for that we've chosen
a technology called pc over ip by a
company called teradici
now there's a lot of different streaming
technologies out there there's a lot of
different protocols out there
but we we've chosen pc over ip because
it provides the highest image fidelity
in that it can display
lossless pixels it can accurately
represent what the remote machine
is providing uh on your client so uh
it has this thing called resolve to
lossless or builds to lossless which
will provide you an uncompressed view of
the pixels on your screen
and then it has the ability to stream
for example uh moving video in a
different codec
uh in different parts of the screen it
also supports things like
high resolution monitors 4k uh and above
monitors
um as well as arbitrary screen
resolutions which is really important
some artists have a 2k monitor in front
of them and then an hd monitor a smaller
hd monitor
as sort of an accessory monitor teradici
can span
multiple monitors and and drive both of
those at independent resolutions
as well as independent frame rates as
well up to 60 frames per second for
example
it's also very flexible when it comes to
bandwidth consumption
so you um you can run teradicity piece
over ip over
over a very small amount of bandwidth if
you've got
a minimal internet at home or via uh
by a phone hotspot or wi-fi uh and then
when you're in the uh in the office or
if you're at home with
uh gig internet you can take advantage
of all that bandwidth and get even
higher quality
but it's totally adaptable and has the
ability to lock um
to to do a vsync and audio sync you'll
see that
as part of the demo and finally uh it's
highly secure in that it's only transmit
transmitting pixels not your data
and those pixels are encrypted as well
another important point i want to uh
i can't stress enough is that teradici
piece over ip supports
more than just keyboard and mouse it
supports things
other input devices such as this wacom
cintiq tablet
that you're going to see me draw
directly on in the demo and it is able
to connect that directly to
my client that goes streams directly
into
my virtual workstation so with that
let's take a look at how
our workflow would look during the demo
so here we are on my mac desktop
and i'm going to log into my virtual
workstation using
uh pcoverip client from teradici this is
a
free download from teradgi.com it runs
on
mac windows linux chrome os and it is a
software client there's also hardware
clients
you could use what's called the xero
client or thin client
to connect and you can connect in a few
different ways depending on how you set
it up
we've set this up not to connect to an
ip address but to a fully qualified
domain name and our domain that we're
using cloud dns through
is editdemo.cloudmediasolutions.dev
and the login flow like we saw in the
diagram will look up my will
authenticate me through
the active directory service so i'm
going to log in using my adrian demo
account
and it's going to authenticate me uh
using
multi-factor authentication so we have a
radius duo server set up in our project
as well
and i can either get a passcode from
google authenticator or i can set up
push notifications which i've set up
which is pretty neat so
i click send me a push and on my phone i
click yes it's me
and i'm authenticated into the cloud
access manager environment
the cloud access manager looks up what
desktops
or resources are assigned to my user and
i've got these three resources assigned
to me they're
virtual workstations one is a virtual
workstation in los angeles another one
is in a different region this one
happens to be in tokyo and another
virtual workstation in los angeles
that's my media encoder
worker utility node so i'm going to
connect to my virtual workstation
now and because i've been authenticated
through the active directory service
all of my user permissions are going to
be matched to that
user identity in windows so once logged
into my workstation
i can see that this is just a standard
windows workstation running
windows server 2019 which includes
windows server
sorry windows desktop experience which
gives me the equivalent of windows 10.
and on this windows workstation i've got
mounted
a cloud volume and netapp cloud volume
and that's mounted to the p drive p
stands for projects and this is a
standard
uh posix file system that's mounted
under smb and because it's mounted under
samba
you get all the standard permissions
that you would with active directory
assignments
and files that i create as me as my user
will be written as me
it is also a shared file system so that
any other user on another workstation
or on a different server windows or
linux
in my project can access these this uh
the cloud volume as well so um in my
lafc edit folder i've got all my assets
and all of my premiere project data and
i've got premiere running
and you can see i've got a fairly uh
straight uh straightforward uh adobe
premiere project
and i've got uh the ability to play
and use standard jkl keys to
uh to play backwards and forwards it's
very responsive all this data by the way
is being read off of that
netapp cloud filer off the p drive so i
can
you know do standard editing tasks
inside premiere and i can
get some pretty good feedback here i can
basically change some of my edit cuts
so that i can build this highlight reel
for example
and i get audio sync as well teradici pc
over ip
supports what's called enhanced av sync
which
will make sure that uh the audio and the
video are locked
uh and accommodate for different uh
bandwidths and
changes in your internet connectivity
and your bandwidth
as bandwidth changes it can adapt it's
also
uh ideal for working with things like
lip sync and
uh and other sort of audio specific
audio
uh sync sensitive workloads so um
and again i'm running at a single
monitor at hd resolution
uh territory also supports multiple
monitors and multiple resolutions
up to 4k and beyond depending on what
your settings are like
and what kind of bandwidth you have
available to you i want to upload some
additional footage to this highlight
reel
from a different game and that footage
happens to be on my local workstation
on my mac so i'm going to hide the
peaceover ip client i don't need to
disconnect to do this
and i'm going to go back to my mac
desktop and i'm going to use a
combination of a couple different things
here i've got
in this folder here i've got some
footage of diego rossi scoring a goal at
a different game and i want to use this
as sort of a
picture-in-picture as part of the
highlight reel so
i'm going to use a combination of a
couple different tools there's this ibm
aspara drive
which will allow me to upload this file
directly to
google cloud storage bucket and aspara
has uh some pretty
uh some pretty interesting proprietary
technology that maximizes your available
bandwidth so
uh from home i only have maybe a 40 or a
50 megabit upload if you
have an enterprise great connection with
gigabit connection or 10 gig
uplink you can be uploading and
streaming
uh many many uh gigabytes per second to
your uh
to your cloud project so i have ibm
esparrow drive set up
and i also am using a combination of
google cloud pub sub
and cloud storage notifications to move
that file once it's in the bucket to
move it into the projects folder
into a specific location and project so
all i have to do is drag and drop
onto ibm aspara drive and it will
perform the synchronization uh and you
can see it's using
30 megabits uh it's not that big of a
file
i'm going to go back to my ps4ip client
and
application and i'm going to go into my
footage transfer directory and there it
is it was transferred
almost instantly so so now it's
available for me to use in my
in my edit and i can just drag that into
my timeline
or into my edit project
and i'm going to make a little bit more
space here
so there's a point of the game where he
misses a shot here he is
so i want to maybe put a little picture
and picture
of that earlier game of that earlier
goal down here so i'm going to just
plunk that into my timeline
make this a little taller and we can
zoom in a little bit
and we can
scale this guy
scale this down maybe and put it up in
the corner
there we go so so now i've just taken
some footage
uh from my local workstation which could
be uh it doesn't need to be on my local
workstation it could be on an on-prem
uh ingestion service uh these files can
be auto-synchronized
uh to and from the netapp file cloud
volume
and i've dropped it into my project here
so
so now what i want to do is some motion
graphics to overlay on top of this to
give
maybe some stats about rosi uh and i'm
going to
bring in my colleague buzz hayes to uh
to collaborate with
uh but first i want to maybe give him
some direction i'm going to switch to
adobe photoshop and i'm going to uh
maybe sketch over top of this
uh this this layout here so that i can
give them some guidance and to do that
i'm going to use a wacom cintiq tablet
that is also attached to this virtual
workstation
one of the cool things about pc over ip
and the software itself
is that it can span multiple desktops
and multiple monitors
so in this case i've got photoshop
running so
uh same adobe creative cloud suite tools
but i've got photoshop running not on on
my mac but on a wacom tablet that's
attached to my mac via usb
and hdmi out so this is a wacom cintiq
hd 24 which is monitor and tablet
combined
and i'm able to use it as an
input device with pressure sensitivity
and what i'm going to do is take this
still image
uh the screen grab of the the point
uh of the edit where we want to bring up
some highlights
for diego rossi's uh goal or sorry his
lack of goal in this case and i want to
uh indicate some
some on-screen graphics to send as a
guide for buzz to work
to work with so i'm just going to add a
couple of input points
there's put an arrow in to indicate the
direction that that element should come
on
and then maybe have some stats on screen
to show
things like uh you know lifetime goals
or career goals or
or season goals and things like that
maybe
a little uh image or photo of rosie
comes up and i'm doing this all on
on the tablet which is attached to the
same virtual workstation
and all able to read and write from the
same
shared file system so i'm going to be
able to send this over to buzz pretty
easily
and just maybe i'll throw in some arrows
to indicate the direction
that these elements should come on
screen
and you'll notice i've got full pressure
sensitivity
and maybe i'll just indicate that this
comes on
from the screen right and goes off on
screen right so
at this point i can just save this off
as a as a png file with an alpha channel
and send that over to buzz for uh to use
as a guide
and i just wanted to be able to
communicate to him my thoughts on
uh where these elements should sit so uh
buzz let's uh let's have a look at this
in after effects thank you adrian
so what i have here is another vm that's
set up it's on the same network and it
is connected to the same
shared file storage as adrian so we have
both have access to all of the elements
that are required for this project
in this case i'm going to be using after
effects to
pull together various elements to be
able to create a motion graphic overlay
that adrian can use
in the edit in premiere now
as part of that i'm going to be using
his reference so as you saw a moment ago
he created a reference here
this gives us some indication as to what
should be on the screen and where it
should be
i like to do a quick comp typically just
to see where things fall on the screen
just make sure i'm not blocking anything
in the background so
i'm going to comp it really quickly over
a still frame of that
section of the video so you can see the
picture-in-picture video up here in the
right corner
and then now we have a text element here
which says date but i think
making a creative decision i'm going to
change that to the player's name
we've got some indications as to how
these elements are moving in we also
have a stats card here that'll appear at
the bottom
and it will have an image of the player
itself
there's some indications here of motion
uh sometimes you have to make the
decisions
of the motion based on the actual
underlying footage because you'll run
into situations where the motion graphic
might block an important part of the
frame depending on
where the camera is or where the subject
of interest is in the frame
so sometimes we have to make creative
decisions and in this case the
underlying
shot is not long enough really to be
able to allow
this graphic element to move all the way
across the frame
and still be readable so i've made an
executive decision to
have a different transition on that
which you'll see in just a moment
so um you can see
in this graphics elements folder i've
i've got a number of graphics elements
here uh one of them
is uh this logo from the lafc that we're
going to use
we also have a headshot of diego rossi
and here's the element that i created in
cinema 4d
so this is a video
of the picture-in-picture piece of it
and
it's basically been rendered into this
frame
um and i've also included the player's
name below the frame and if you
notice there's a subtle light glint
that's happening across there especially
in this section here you'll see a light
plane
this is just to give the graphic itself
some life when it's on the frame so it
doesn't look too static
but this will be an element that is used
to
bring in that picture in picture and
anything you see that's black here in
the frame is actually going to be
transparent
in the final composite that's important
so that it looks nice and clean when you
put it together
so i've pre-built a sequence here that
has all of these elements in it
as you can see here in the layer side of
things i've got a number of text
elements that are
native text within after effects i have
the
the logo that we mentioned a minute ago
from the lafc
and then i have the head shot of the
player i have a couple of shapes here
which i'll show you in a second
and then i have the bottom here i have
the motion graphics element so
as i play this uh in slo-mo here i'll
just drag through the timeline you'll
notice as it comes in it looks a little
bit blurry
that's because i've added motion blur to
it because we're dealing with video
frame rates sometimes motion graphics
look a little stuttery or jittery
so the best way to counteract that is to
enable uh motion blur
and so if you look over here in the
timeline
there's a little uh in indicator here
which uh is the motion blur setting
and it essentially uh emulates what a
camera shutter would do
um so there's a natural motion blur that
happens in
in normal cameras so this is emulating
that so if i i've turned this on for all
the layers because
basically all the layers are moving at
some point so that will give them a nice
smooth motion so as you can see again as
it moves in you see the leading edge is
a little bit blurred
and then as this graphic element at the
bottom this is the change i made where
it's rotating in now instead of sliding
in
it has a little bit of motion blur right
there at the beginning as it comes in
and then it settles so it's in nice
sharp focus
so now that all these elements are
together and
the timing seems to fit well now what
i'm going to do is take this particular
element
and i'm going to render it out i'm going
to add it to the render queue
in this case i'm not going to use the
adobe media encoder
render queue which i could do because
that's on another vm that adrian has set
up on this
network but this is such a small render
it's actually very quick to do right
here on the machine
so here i'm going to set an output
format of quicktime and
under format i'm going to choose the
apple prores 444 format
and the reason for that is because the
prores
not all the prores formats support alpha
channels
again alpha channels are the ability to
present
this area around the graphics as
transparent
if i were to render this in the other
prores codecs that don't support alpha
channels
this would just come out as a giant
black rectangle with these
elements in it and when i bring it into
premiere it would obscure
the video from underneath so as long as
i've chosen the alpha channel here
then i will have this nice transparent
background
this particular clip has no audio so i'm
just going to turn that off
and the output file name is set down
here
we're all ready to go you can see how
quick the render goes it's going to play
it in real time here
as it renders because again it's a very
quick render now if i were doing a lot
of renders
if i had a pile of motion graphics that
i was going to be doing then i would
most
likely be taking all of these renders
out to the media encoder
so that i could keep working uh by using
the local
queue here in after effects i'm tying up
the application itself so i can't keep
working but if i were to send it off to
the render queue
i could keep working so without further
ado i'm going to turn this over to
adrian so he can take this clip
that we just generated as an overlay
graphic and drop it into his edit on
premiere
so thank you and take it away adrian
thanks buzz i'm going to take those
graphics that you output and drag them
into my timeline
and because they're on the shared file
system we could both see the same files
and the same assets so i can just go to
that directory and grab it
from the output location i'm going to
pop that in
there's the footage it's ready to go so
i'm ready to render this and there's a
few different ways to render adobe
premiere projects
i could render it locally on my
workstation but i can also
farm it off to a separate node and i've
got this separate node running adobe
media encoder
in my same project and i could see that
here i've got another pcrp client
running
so i've got it ready to go and it's
watching a watch folder it's looking at
the media encoder transcoder folder so
any file that gets saved into there will
get
automatically transcoded so i'm going to
save a copy into that location i've got
it here on my sidebar
and
[Music]
save a copy there so when i go back and
watch media encoder
you can see it automatically picks up
that render job
and it's going to run a number of
different formats out so i've got things
like youtube 1080p
and a low res proxy some other output
formats here as well
so once that's done we can
it's going to write the final output to
that same folder but in the outputs
folder
and we can go and uh look at the results
on our workstation and view the final
renders in real time
with a frame viewer so i can go into the
transcoder folder here
and go into output and then let's look
at maybe
one of the youtube 1080p files here
this is the latest one here i'm going to
open it with
djv which is an open source frame viewer
and there it is there's our final
final render so uh maybe look over here
there's there's the graphics that we
added
well let's go back and watch them come
on there they go so there's the graphics
that we added
so now that we've got all of our assets
written to disk and we've got the
different formats written out
we could continue our workflow by
exporting these
for to object store to connect to a cdn
with one of our cdn partners
you could run them through any number of
machine learning apis
to understand them better and be able to
tag them and monetize them properly
and that's there's a lot of partner
technology as well
that we can use to feed these to a media
asset management system
for example let's look at what we saw as
part of this demo
i logged in through active directory
using multi-factor authentication
i went in through a connection broker
the connection broker realized i was in
los angeles and connected me to my
workstation
in los angeles i was able to edit some
footage using adobe premiere pro
with full interactivity and very low
latency i was also able to draw on this
tablet
and draw some notes for buzz i handed
those files over to buzz
over our shared file system where buzz
accessed his own virtual workstation in
a similar manner
performed activities and then saved that
data back for me to grab
and then finally i rendered the content
on a separate machine
that is operating as my media encoder
server uh watching a watch directory and
then i was able to finally take the
output video
view that scrub through it to verify
that it was okay
and all that was streaming over teradici
pc over ip
with a full video quality on on this for
example on this 2k monitor
with also my cintiq tablet attached so
what we didn't have time to show as part
of this demo is
a more advanced ingestion strategy you
did see me use aspara drive to drag that
file
uh and upload it automatically and put
that on the netapp cloud volume
but if you have massive amounts of data
for example you're on
a set and you have terabytes of data to
upload you're going to need to define an
asset
uh ingestion strategy and there's a
bunch of technologies
both native and partner technologies on
gcp to allow you to
to do that we also didn't talk about
things like disaster recovery
and asset management um we this our our
workflow did not
require an asset management system but
we have a lot of
uh isvs independent software vendors
that we work with that provide asset
managers
um there's also the notion of disaster
recovery for
moving uh allowing you to operate in any
region
in in your geographic location or in the
world
as part of a contingency plan i want to
bring buzz in to talk a little bit
further about
how to monetize and uh get more out of
your
archive using something called
intelligent content discovery
buzz thanks adrian so yes with
intelligent content discovery you know
you hear a lot about
machine learning and artificial
intelligence tools that can
automatically derive metadata both on
the visual content and the audio content
in files
but how we use that metadata is really
important especially when it comes to
monetizing
the content itself so obviously the
metadata is important when we're trying
to find the content while we're still
working with it while we're producing
the finished goods
but there's also um it's important to
note that the metadata comes into play
when
you're actually trying to leverage the
finished goods so for example in
the use of recommendation engines or
personalization
artificial intelligence tools that are
leveraging this metadata can actually be
very effective
in the distribution side of things as
well as in the effort to be able to
create
new assets from the existing so for
example if you're making trailers or
teasers or things like that
they can be tailored to a very specific
demographic using
ai for example or at least the metadata
that's associated with this content so
you can have a very tailored view of the
content
as we get closer and closer to this
direct consumer world
and then in terms of regionalization
obviously as we deliver assets these
days it used to be that there was a time
delay between
the north american release of something
and the european or worldwide release
now they tend to be day and date which
means that all of the different versions
and there can be
literally thousands of versions have to
be deployed at the same time so there
has to be some automation
involved in creating these localized
versions as well as
in how this uh the entire process of
localization happens and where that
happens
so as adrian mentioned before we have a
fairly
extensive ecosystem of partners and
our partners cover everything from the
production side to content management
the country distribution as well as the
consumer goods
services and management of the the
resources themselves
as you can see here we have partners
from all over the place and this
list is ever growing but all of these
become very important factors when
you're looking at a virtual studio
deployment or a virtual post-production
suite
because many of these folks have already
deployed cloud-native versions of their
software or they're working on
cloud-native versions or their existing
versions can actually work on
cloud-based vms so it's important to
note that we have this very extensive
network
so with that i'd like to thank you all
for your attention today if you want to
learn anything more about our media
solutions please visit our website as
you see here
uh there's plenty of information there
for you to have and you're
also welcome to talk to our google sales
team um but with that i would like to
thank on behalf of adrian and myself
thank you all for your time and go out
there and build your own virtual pulse
production
suite thank you